[Music]
[Applause]
David Pollock three-time allamerican in
Georgia and former ESPN college football
analyst joining us on the program all
right let me start with Alabama and
Auburn how does that happen how does
that happen David Auburn that's the only
thing you need to say is Auburn
Auburn I feel bad man you mentioned the
patrons it makes me think of the Jets
you know like some the stuff that have
happened to the Jets over the years but
I I was sitting there with my son and I
lit my son goes he's a ninth grader he
goes Rush two and drop everybody else I
go no no no no I said I'm bringing at
least four because you get so much time
in the pocket otherwise and they're
going to buy time and eventually 53 yard
field somebody's gonna have a chance you
can't cover all the grass but I didn't
think Auburn did a good job you can't
turn your back to the quarterback you
can't not see the football on a 40 yard
pass coming down the field your feet
should be set in the end zone um only
Auburn feel bad for him man because they
had the game one dropped the punt you
know late in the football game gave
Alabama the chance and just like Alabama
does so many times they take advantage
of it imagine if Alabama had lost that
game heading into this game against
Georgia you know remember a couple years
ago when Georgia was one they had that
overtime Thriller with auburn and it
took the the sales out of it everybody
said Alabama's done they looked horrible
Bryce Young sacked 12 times something
like that it definitely would have
changed the dynamic but Alabama still
you know in the playoff picture they
still got Texas but um it would have
taken some of the steam out of this game
but this game is going to be awesome
regardless yeah you have that game
coming up uh Michigan against Ohio State
uh The Fallout from that does Ohio State
Should Ohio State stay in the top
four no absolutely not they shouldn't
stay in the top four and and I I would
take them out now of the top the five
six seven I'd put him behind Bama and
and listen here's the thing with Ohio
State to me Ryan day is now 40 and0 Dan
against the Big 10 and one and three
against Michigan like and to me that
there there's one reason and this is
gonna sting Ohio State fans a little bit
but it's toughness like Michigan lives
in a state of tough you know listen Ohio
State Credit to them you can tell
they've worked on it they want to be
more physical they want to run the
football but that's who Michigan is
constantly they've won the rushing
battle the last years the reason they've
won it but no I think Ohio state would
need listen if you watch their offense
they're okay I mean they're they're
pretty good they're they're not an elite
offense they're not a great offense we
remember the Notre Dame game another
good opponent they played early in the
season like I think Ohio State's good I
don't think they're final
four is Ryan Day on the hot
seat no I I don't think he is I I think
that when you uh when you look at 40
and0 versus the the Big 10 and then one
and three versus Michigan I I put this
way I don't think he's gonna get fired
does does this bring more pressure to
him yes not only have you lost to
harball now you lost to an interim coach
like that's not that's not good but man
it's hard to say somebody that's been
that successful you're gonna fire him
I'm not saying it'd be unprecedented but
the dude's made the college football
playoff a couple times he's been there
um but I definitely think this is
disappointing this hurts this stings
it's something that's going to leave a
bad taste in your mouth but man are you
going to fire a guy that's been this
successful and this good I don't see
that happen yeah but you know what this
comes down to it's can you beat Michigan
can you beat Ohio State you can beat
Purdue and Indiana and Minnesota nobody
cares Penn State yeah nobody cares yeah
and and winning big games and they
haven't won big games I mean you see
against Georgia they had an opportunity
to win the game but they didn't and
they've been there to win to big games I
I get it I understand it I just who else
are you going to go get now and be like
oh yeah that's the guy like that's the
guy that's going to replace Ryan day and
be a clearcut above what he's been able
to accomplish okay let me go back to the
toughness thing because Lou Holtz
brought this up others have brought this
up that Ryan day doesn't have tough
teams uh how do you get a tough
team toughness isn't like a something
that's that's all of a sudden
manufactured on game day like toughness
is the way you live toughness is the way
you practice every single day it's the
way you talk to the kids like you have
to bring energy and effort and toughness
every single day if your teams take on
the Persona of your coaches that's a
fact like however you live constantly so
I think because they've been so spread
throw the football like running the
football was kind of an afterthought I
think it's been kind of left behind I
I'll say this this game Ohio State
wasn't manhandled like they have been in
the past they showed more toughness
fourth down and short though I got to
see you believe in yourself and in your
team and you got to go for it it's it's
a couple mistakes away but toughness is
something that is is given to your team
through you the way you coached them and
the way you take them through practice
every single day I never thought in my
lifetime that Texas A&M would hire a
head coach and hire that coach away from
duke right yeah I mean yes but when this
when this came up though with A&M I
thought Elco was a was a great fit for a
couple reasons like he's already been
there he knows the culture of A&M super
successful he's also the opposite of
Jimbo Fisher Jimbo Fisher is a different
bird
and I I don't know Jimbo Fisher's done a
really good job accumulating talent but
a zero good job of doing this and
bringing people together and obviously
IO ELO was not the first you know name
that they had on their list and they
went after other people and and so be it
but I think really really good defensive
coach really really good dude
disciplined tough not going to be uh
Jimbo esque everybody will be excited to
see what they do on offense because you
know Jimbo and the offense obviously has
been lacking behind for the last several
years yeah they got to get a quarterback
can't they buy a good
quarterback with all that oil money dog
you you figure right I mean they're
spending it I mean and here's the thing
like you spent all that money to buy
Jimbo out now you gotta spend now you
got to get everybody excited again and
you got to get everybody giving again
and I know all that money there is
different than our money like it's kind
of change cushion compared to me and
your bank roles and not I ain't in Dan's
World either by the way but like it's
it's the money's there the spending is
going to be there so I need somebody
that can develop somebody that can build
a culture and and I think that's why
ELO's your guy this was like the last
weekend of college football as we know
it you know with the Pack 12 you know
Big 10 SEC playoffs all of those things
what concerns you the most moving
forward well I think the we've already
lost the rivalries those are those are
gone um the travel across the country
like it's going to be strange man and
and you you obviously kill most of the
budgets of a lot of other teams and the
off season they're going to have to be
inconvenience the most football won't be
inconvenience as much but I think just
losing the the luster that was college
football losing the Traditions losing
the passions some of that stuff man I
know it's it's like the old guy talking
probably and I love watching this I love
watching that but a lot of those things
are going to be gone a lot of those
rivalries are going to be gone a lot of
those coaching staff and those teams
like a team like Washington State who
almost beat Washington like where do
they go do they fall off the map now do
they I mean Oregon State you know their
coach now goes to Michigan State
obviously like do they fall off the map
like I just I I it stinks for those type
of programs that we've had we've seen
some history we've seen some cool things
from and those those things where do
they go now who gets your Heisman vote
Jaden Daniels I mean listen people are
going to come at me I know for for the
three losses but dude if you watch
college football every weekend I have a
standing tweet every Saturday Jaden
Daniels is the best player in college
football Jaden Daniels is the best
player in college football he's got 90
he's got 90 plays of 20 plus yards or
more you know what the next closest is
Dan
61 61 like he is he's a human highlight
film he can't control that his defenses
suck but man over 1100 yards rushing
over 50 touchdowns and if you want to
talk about over 50 touchdowns that's
that's Cam Newton that's Joe burrow
that's TBO that's that type of you know
numbers that he's put up this year he's
he's the best player I've seen I'm so
interested to see him go to the next
level because he's got some Lamar to him
some of that shake and that slight build
but throws the football a lot better
especially at this point in his career
but man he's to me every every every
week I turn on the television I watch
he's the best player and then you got
probably the two favorites they're both
transfers with you know D Daniels and Bo
Knicks yeah and and Bo Knick is really
really good and how about that story Dan
like bonick comes in as a freshman you
know to Auburn his dad's alma mater you
know beats Oregon and then and then the
sizzle comes off and the program leaves
and then he goes and rebuilds himself
and I'll tell you this too I I think B
Knicks is a first round pick like that's
how much his story has been turned
around of being left for gone and now
leads the nation to complet some
percentage passing yards like doing a
great job carrying Oregon I just and
he's a great player but watching him and
Jaden Daniels the rushing component the
explosive play component man that that's
to me the separator but I wonder though
this weekend with Oregon and Washington
and if B Knicks has a big game this is
you know everybody has to have a
standalone game and he would have
another opportunity for a standalone
game where Daniels would not 100% and
listen the voters in the past they want
you to be on a national championship
Contender and so I think you got penck
and nicks both still alive the
Washington quarterback his best game one
of his best games was against Oregon he
goes and lights up Oregon again I think
people are gonna be like wait a minute
you got to be on a championship team
which I don't agree with by the way that
doesn't make you the best player because
you have the best team around you that I
don't agree with that at all I never
have and the way I vote isn't that way
but B Knicks has an opportunity a stage
avenge a loss after last week too
against Oregon State you been a really
good ranked opponent damn that's the
best he's looked they were explosive it
wasn't Dink and dunk like he was taking
shots it was him making big time plays
you do it again against Washington with
everybody watching you could go get that
thing great to talk to you again thank
you bud great to hear from you Dan see
Brother David Pollock uh three-time
allamerican of Georgia and a member of
the College Football Hall of Fame and
former ESPN college football analyst